[Musik]
in der engadiner bergwelt liegt das
hochalpine institut
hier lernen und wohnen schüler von nah
und fern
zeva aus sankt petersburg befindet sich
im letzten jahr des gymnasiums
schulkollegin batliner wohnt in school
und besucht die sportklasse
auch für robin aus der innerschweiz
können sich nun die weichen fürs leben
ein team von internetbetrügern kümmert
sich um die freuden und sorgen der
jugendlichen
und gerhard steuble amt als rektor des
traditionsreichen instituts
für alle ist es das jahr der
entscheidungen
[Musik]
hektik im hochalpinen institute an einem
tag im herbst
rektor gerhard steudter ist im obersten
stock des schulhauses
[Musik]
leere klassenzimmer sind ansonsten eher
etwas das gerhard steuble nicht gerne
sieht
[Musik]
in der letzten sendung der
internatsschule sorgte sich der rektor
um den schülerrückgang an seinem
institut
[Musik]
für seine maturaarbeit gegen robin fix
in den ball
fünf tage wollte er hier überleben mit
minimaler ausrüstung
seiner guidance trainierte im kraftraum
für ihr großes ziel den engadiner frauen
laufen
[Musik]
und statt schlussspurt im abschlussjahr
ließ sich selber pusch gehen im
unterricht gehen
bist du müde ein stillleben liegend auf
dem tisch großartig
die schüler versammeln sich auf der
wiese vor dem hochalpinen institut so
schreiben es die abläufe vor bei einem
ernstfall heute war es nur eine
feuerwehr über
obwohl es nur ein test ist rektor
steuble absolviert ein
ernsthaftes problem sie wie zb großen
träger
amoklauf verträgen zurück
von den schülern aus der ersten
sekundarstufe bis zu den gymnasiasten
der abschlussklasse alle versammeln sich
130 schüler insgesamt
rektor steuble wird begleitet von seinem
prorektor kurt leitl
auch wenn ihr hundertmal überzeugt seit
es ist ein fehlalarm heraus und trifft
sich hier herunter und dann wird sagt ok
man kann zurückgehen oder es ist nicht
okay und wir gehen hin unter nachbarn
oder was sonst danke für eure mitteln
und jetzt hat direkt und was zu sagen
meine aufgabe werde man alarmismus
schulhaus sorgen dass jobs leer ist ich
verliere viel zeit in dem mit zimmer
wieder muss auch flüsse wo wann ich sie
auch gesehen dass die dänen klaus
vorschule und ich wäre sehr viel
schneller durch sure lust oder wenn die
das nicht jedes mal muss machen danke
vielmals
ende der feuerwehr übung die schüler
kehren zurück zum unterricht
in nicht allzu ferner zeit werden andere
alarmzeichen auftauchen die ernster zu
nehmen sind
[Musik]
in der abschlussklasse sex geht es
weiter mit spanisch ein sogenanntes
ergänzungsfach dass ein drittel der
klasse gewählt hat
um hier
[Musik]
robin thicke es kommt zu spät
wo bist du dich hinsetzen die mädels
sitzen alle zusammen und haben sich
alleine gelassen
nein nicht dort hinten da sehe ich dich
nicht
eigentlich sollte robin ja gar nicht im
unterricht sein sondern draußen im wald
sein survival abenteuer musste er jedoch
verfrüht abbrechen
zeva puschkin hat eine freistunde er
schreibt an seiner maturaarbeit sein
thema wie mit augenbewegungen computer
gesteuert werden können als erstes muss
er ein poster gestalten der abgabetermin
steht kurz bevor
sie war ist im vierten jahr im internet
der russe aus sankt petersburg ist am
institut weil sich seine eltern hier
eine bessere ausbildung erhoffen als in
der heimat webers vater bezahlt 45.000
franken pro jahr dafür will er leistung
sehen
[Musik]
du musst du musst ihn war die
präsentation machen dann muss das bis
dienstag machen anders geht nicht
das heißt egal wenn du das machst
dienstag wussten das waren ich
bin schon wer hat schon vollkommen recht
weil der älteste jahre wenn ich einmal
war ganz schwierig und waren irgendwie
ich war noch
jung vor drei jahren waren das ich war
16 15 sogar da habe ich habe ich bin ich
jemand mit helfern gemeinden dieses bin
ich frei einfach
aber ich bin nein ich kann machen was
ich will ich kann nicht schlafen wie
esswein sind leute und dann ist war das
von neuen deswegen habe ich gelernt habe
nachher bin ich fast aus der schule
geflogen und alles viel besser da silva
bleibt nur noch ein tag zeit um sein
matura poster fertigzustellen
[Musik]
fast jeder chef hat nochmals einen
vorgesetzten rektor steuble ist
unterwegs mit professor doktor rolf dubs
dem verwaltungsratspräsidenten der
hochalpines instituten ag eine sitzung
des verwaltungsrates ist anberaumt
das institut ist als aktiengesellschaft
organisiert gewinn zu erwirtschaften ist
nicht das primäre ziel aber natürlich
muss sich der betrieb rechnet
[Musik]
aufgrund der rückläufigen schülerzahlen
sind die finanzen ein zentrales thema an
dieser sitzung ebenso die frage wie man
wieder mehr schüler nach tann bringen
könnte
[Musik]
das hochalpine instituten ist eine
schule mit 2 100 jähriger tradition
im lauf der zeit muss sie sich stetig
anpassen diese herausforderungen stellen
sich der leitung dieser schule die
internatsschüler treiben ganz andere
fragen um sie sollten die schulischen
leistungen bringen leben die ganze zeit
hier oben müssen sich mit den anderen
jugendlichen arrangieren
und sich manchmal auch hinten anstellen
jedenfalls solange sie noch nicht zu den
großen schülern gehören
internats mitarbeiterin ruth berger
nutzt dance juni für eine bekanntmachung
[Musik]
heute arbeitet ruth bei einer
tragschicht bald wird sie von zwei
kollegen abgelöst werden
die verwaltungsratssitzung ist noch
nicht beendet doch gerhard steuble und
seine beiden prorektoren haben die
besprechung bereits verlassen
es ist hier am institut so üblich dass
sich die verwaltungsräte am schluss der
sitzung nur unter sich austauschen
rektor steuble und sein team werden erst
später über die beschlüsse des
verwaltungsrates informiert
soviel vorweg es sind einschneidende
maßnahmen
die abendstunden am institut sind
reserviert für die hausaufgaben die
studienzeiten sind klar geregelt
es ist aufgabe der internetbetrüger die
studienzeit zu überwachen
heute übernimmt internatsleiter jens
bauer den dienst
jene schüler mit einem notenschnitt
unter 4,5 haben pro tag zwei stunden
studienzeit unter einer 5 eine stunde
die besten schüler können in ihren
zimmern frei lernen ebenso die ältesten
jungs auf der vierten etage
internats betreuer tobias stock macht
eine kleine kontrollrunde
studienzeit leute
kultur
steht dann
werden so dass die kultur das ist spaß
natürlich 51 finale das ist gut so und
jetzt macht das ding zu machen doch was
für die schule okay
ja aber ehrlich
da willst du bist dran
über
einen wurm reaktor
spezialisierung abfahren was ihn eine
woche und das in teterow misst während
normaler kompost werden dazu wurde
bobby keys hat da ein bisschen
seiner klassen kollegin lucia hilft ihm
bei der arbeit zum thema survival
fünf tage wollte robin alleine im wald
überleben doch nach drei tagen musste er
die übung erschöpft abbrechen in seinem
video tagebuch berichtet er über das
leiden sich nur von heidelbeeren und
heuschrecken ernähren zu können
[Musik]
verbraucher klagen und jugendlichenalter
obwohl ich habe geschichten ak aber ich
habe
gar
keine produziert werden
krasniqi
im
magazin wertlos machen also etwas stehen
daran wenn wir das nicht erlaubt hätte
ich mir vorstellen dass man irgendwie
dank der hat doch sicher nur könnte
jetzt doch nur schwach oder après ski es
ist so psychisch es mache ich so kaputt
einfach falsch nicht sein
und dennoch isoliert sie einsam sie mit
niemandem reden dass das alles factor
oder wir
jetzt mal wieder runter
klassen kollegin lucia wohnt nicht im
internet sondern unten im tal
robin ist nun fertig mit seinem matura
poster er beginnt mit der arbeit für
seinen großen vortrag in der aula
versuchen
auch sie war lässt sich bei der matura
arbeit helfen allerdings sitzt seine
unterstützung 2000 kilometer weit
entfernt vor einem computer
hladik sein bester freund aus sankt
petersburg mit
russischer fällen hilfe wie sie war das
matura poster bis morgen fertig stellen
er hat zwar den text aber vom poster ist
noch nichts zu sehen
ich habe noch mit meiner person gar
nicht angefangen was ich sage so
den spulen wohnt eine dieser externen
mal eine potenz
zum glück
hat er ziemlich viel zeit braucht mehr
als erwartet
madonna hat ihr matura poster zum thema
paralympische spiele gestaltet
abseits der schule nimmt sie sich vor
allem für zwei dinge zeit
sport und musik
seit acht jahren geht sie regelmäßig zum
klavierunterricht
abstand mal ein besonderes machen
zwischen der viele hose sehr kurz und
so freuen ihre musik und heutige musik
und das sehr spannend
[Musik]
der unterricht findet in matt liners
muttersprache statt dem rätoromanischen
[Musik]
die post berichtet
strahlend erwacht der tag über dem
hochalpinen instituts
[Musik]
in dieser idyllische stimmung nicht sich
laute musik aus dem mädcheninternat
[Musik]
viele
diese gebiete wie
drüben im buben trakt arbeitet sie war
immer nur an seine matura poster viel zu
sehen gibt es nach wie vor nicht
[Musik]
sein russischer freund lattek ist
ebenfalls schon wach sie war
fotografiert für ihn denn zart blauem
hintergrund des posters
und ersten jesus wort kommt ich schicke
dir mal was ich denke und dann sagt er
ist gut nicht gut
da gibt sich hat das schleppt kontakt
gestern aber ich noch durch die nacht
wenn wächst zusammen und fertig dann
haben wir doch noch papier sein wie das
aussieht aber dann wollte ich schlafen
gehe nicht schlafen gegangen
da bleiben nur noch wenige stunden bis
das poster fertig sein muss
mit gewichtigeren sorgen ist rektor
gerhard steuble konfrontiert nach der
letzten verwaltungsratssitzung hat er
den auftrag bekommen ein betriebs budget
zu erstellen das sich auch mit der
derzeit tief schülerzahl finanzieren
lässt
wirklich jetzt auch riesig macht
und die situation
wohl alle abteilungen kraft
und meine frage vor allem grüner magath
und hoffen höhere margen
ich biete einen anschluss an irgendwie
müsse zu einer
die zahlen irgendwo umsätzen ihnen
erkenntnis und die erkenntnis heißt dass
man sehr sehr viel geld sparen aus einem
internat fange gerade der ton ist
situation zur pensenreduktionen für die
gesamtzahl um 50 prozent
die einzige ecke wo wir noch eine
möglichkeit haben also bei es muss ja
trotzdem zumindest eine person muss
irgendwie immer da sein als wir werden
nicht in der studienzeit sparen können
das geht nicht weil das ist unser
auftrag der hauptsächlich haben auch
diese studienzeit betreuen gut dass das
war also quasi die news verurteilt wurde
der namenlose vortritt im schulbetrieb
und die heißt
24 kollektion reduzieren
dann haben wir reduktion von valve
bietet das tut desto natürlicher
weil es verrückt und die konkurrenz auf
total mit sieben bergen
[Musik]
die schülerinnen und schüler der
abschlussklasse machen sich bereit für
die präsentation ihrer matura poster auf
den letzten drücker schafft es auch noch
sewa
[Musik]
das matura poster ist nur der erste
schritt im rahmen der ganzen
abschlussarbeit ein vortrag und
natürlich die matura arbeit selber sind
zusätzlich gefordert
die lehrer und auch schüler anderer
klassen sind eingeladen sich die poster
nun genauer anzuschauen
die abschluss klässler müssen rede und
antwort stehen
[Musik]
ich mache mir leid
batliner erhält für ihr poster eine sehr
gute note
schlecht geworden sei
was poster wird jedoch mit einer klar
ungenügende note bewertet
robin wiederum schneidet ausgezeichnet
ab
von dem können die mieter wert von
gamezone
für robbie steht bald der nächste test
an der mature vortrag vor großem
publikum
das hochalpine institute liegt auf 1700
meter höhe kaum anzunehmen dass hier
jemand unter freiem himmel schlafen
möchte diese matratzen kamen von
irgendwo da oben geflogen
[Musik]
oben im dritten stock roth berner hat
zwar schnell herausgefunden wo die
matratzen fehlen aber wer sie
rausgeworfen hat das will niemand
verraten selbst die geschädigten nicht
[Musik]
wir haben zu machen
selbst gesehen haben
achse des jahres frau
ruth berger hat den vorfall bereits in
der nacht weiter jens brauer gemeldet
zweimal 13 sind draußen um so welten und
andere sachen tisch und sorgen sie alles
raus genommen aber ich weiß wirklich
nicht wer was wann gemacht hat ob sie
untereinander stimmt haben ich habe zu
hause lassen
jens bauer will sich selber einen
überblick verschaffen in welchem zimmer
etwas fehlt und
wohin es bull gekommen ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im internet büro schauern abschluss
klässler auf ein paar früchte vorbei als
älteste im internat wissen sie in der
regel alles was hier abläuft außer
diesmal
[Musik]
niemand weiß etwas und die opfer die was
wissen wollen niemand verletzten david
brenner die spitzbuben nicht auf
frischer tat ertappt hat hat sie keine
chance
am abend in der aula robin ist
angespannt gleich muss er seinen matura
vortrag halten vor versammeltem publikum
auch robbins freundin ist gekommen und
seine eltern die mutter ist sogar extra
aus argentinien angereist
[Musik]
ein weiteres familienmitglied wird per
skype zugeschaltet
robin schwester liegt in chile
[Musik]
im internet büro ist grant fletcher
eingetroffen er übernimmt die aufsicht
während seine kollegen an robbins
vortrag gehen
nach den vorfällen mit den matratzen ist
erhöhte aufmerksamkeit gefordert
[Musik]
rektor gerhard steuble ist mit seiner
frau heidi gekommen
meine damen und herren ich begrüße sie
recht herzlich zu meiner matura arbeits
präsentation über das thema survival die
kunst des überlebens außerhalb der
zivilisation
dass ich mich für das thema survival
entschieden hatte wollte ich natürlich
etwas praktisches machen und ich wollte
nur überlebenstrieb den drang zu
überleben wird sich selber erfahren
meine zentrale leitfrage war es wie
überlebt man in der natur und
schließlich ähnelt sich das später auf
den alltag aus
[Musik]
im dritten stock des buben internet
wacht grant fletcher darüber dass alles
ruhig bleibt
ich habe ein paar verdächtige im visier
ich will nur schauen was sie
vorhaben
ein fehlalarm
die bogen bleiben brav
robin hat seinen vortrag beendet und
lässt sich gratulieren
am liebsten umarmt er seine freundin
über
rektor steuble unterhält sich mit robins
mutter von argentinien aus kommuniziert
sie mit ihrem sohn ständig über das
handy
in kontakt
diesen diesem schrank in dem kleinen
zimmer und torten
ja es ist so wie
wir mal wie wir im nächsten dorf während
ich bin halt auch darum ist dieses jahr
dort auf der anderen seite des ozeans
führt robins mutter eine firma
über den sommer ist sie jeweils für ein
paar wochen bei ihrem sohn in der
schweiz
der verein
liga haben
[Musik]
mit der stark am herzen weil
feste sollen gefeiert werden die sie
fallen denn wer weiß schon wie lange man
ohne sorgenfreien kann unverhofft
tauchen probleme auf mit denen niemand
gerechnet hat
[Musik]
zwei monate später ist der schnee
gekommen
[Musik]
die erste hälfte des schuljahres verlief
in normalen bahnen
mit dem einzug des winters wird alles
anders dem hochalpinen institut bläst
plötzlich ein kalter wind entgegen
und mitten im sturm rektor gerhard
steuble
[Musik]
die größte bündner tageszeitung
kritisiert auf der frontseite das
hochalpine instituten massiv
[Musik]
von pädagogischen skandalen ist die rede
von abwesenheiten ohne folgen und dass
die schulleitung internatsschüler
bevorzugt behandelt die zeitung stützt
sich auf aussagen zweier ehemaliger
lehrer eine davon anonym der
schwerwiegendste vorwurf lautet dass
abschlussnoten manipuliert werden
zitiert wird das ist eine leere wohnung
irgendwo liegen entlang
und manipuliert indem sehen muss sie das
oft komplett zurück weil das einfach
durch durch all die kontrollmechanismen
schlicht nicht möglich ist dass man das
macht
es ist ärgerlich also ich ärgere mich
natürlich furchtbar weil
mit der gesamtsituation habe ich gesehen
dass wir
sehr betroffen sind von denen artig und
lehrer wo angesprochen werden
ufa pauschalisierende ort und wie ist
auch jetzt im innere situation
innenstadt und die belastung jetzt
mitarbeiter an bissig ibis ist internat
wir sind sport das ist umverteilung der
ganzen geschichte
mario zankl der klassenlehrer der 6g
gehört zu den betroffenen der kritischen
berichterstattung
er macht den artikel zum thema in der
abschlussklasse
spezialprogramm was ich gerne hätte
wäre das ihr mich sozusagen
update auf gleis damit ich weiß was
davon haltet vor allem ja
einmal mehr sind jetzt in den abschluss
den grund sonic gut wenn es denn heißt
es sind die noten sind geschenkt die
abschlussnote das ist analyse sowie zum
nachdenken wie es denn nichts wäre
setzen ohne bewerten den heißt ja ich
bin ein mensch der teufel gemacht
also ich verdiene mir meine noten schon
und ich finde schon dass ich für meine
noten auch was mache und dass ich die
nicht einfach so da vorgeworfen bekomme
in der 6g sitzen zur hälfte schüler aus
dem internat und so hälfte schüler aus
der region
rektor steuble führt quasi zwei schulen
in einer eine privatschule und eine
öffentliche schule
bei den schülern aus dem tal den
externen bestimmter kantonen die
aufnahmebedingungen übernimmt dafür aber
auch die kosten
die internen dagegen bezahlen die
schulgebühren aus eigener tasche und
rektor steuble steht es frei welche
dieser schüler er aufnehmen will
am institut würden die internen
begünstigt so die anschuldigungen in der
presse es gelte die maxime wer zahlt
befiehlt
ich glaube es entspricht
es gibt dort wo immer die klischees
wieder gern bestätigt hat die beruht
darauf dass
die entstehende eigentlich bitte
aufnahmeprüfung jedes kind aus dem
kanton graubünden wo es war
einsatzmittel
solche mittel staat muss es duft die
icon ist die kantonale aufnahmeprüfung
bestehen dass ein einheitsbrei afrika
limacher täglich grafik und dann geld
fällig tour und dann beobachtet wenn es
anders kind aus dem unterland kräftig
muss machen und in aachen und das wird
dann auch sehr ungerecht empfunden dass
aufzug natürlich größer und immer wieder
modems ist ja das ist bloss wer geld hat
und - gehalt die prüfung müsse machen
und ist jetzt nach und ich glaube dass
ich so der ursprung von ganzer konflikt
aus wirtschaftlichen gründen ist das
hochalpine institut auf interne wie auch
externe jugendliche angewiesen ansonsten
wäre die anzahl schüler schlicht zu
klein wir haben immer das problem intern
extern sagt ihr dass es das problem gibt
intern extern und das wäre für mich
wichtig also eigentlich eure meinung zu
dem ganzen
das bis jetzt noch nie bemerkt und
sofort stelle das feuer griff bereits
vorgenommen ich habe einfach vorstellen
dass du mich spielen externe trend
völlig demoliert und trotzdem liebe ich
mein vielen internet muss ich glaub mir
deine chance des
externen
das nicht glaubt dadurch hätten interne
pflichten vorteil aber in der schule
sucht also im klassenzimmer war es genau
gleich also dienten vorteil bieten ort
anbieter nicht
einfach viele stämme vans schießtag
mache so etwas kaputt ist
sind 170
das ist diese
darum die ganze woche bonito
uns darum
dass jedes jahr zuvor
sachbeschädigung also regen wird das
scheiß gemacht wird wir sind wir mit
zither und somit 70
so
gut dann machen wir unsere tore fünf
minuten pause jetzt und danach die
englischen bis zum mittag essen
einer hat gefehlt im unterricht
[Musik]
draußen im schneetreiben dreht man
leider gaudenz ihre langlauf runden
kleiner wird trainiert vom norweger
odyssey wachsen sie wird sein ist der
mann der einst dario cologna entdeckte
und zum weltklasse athleten formte
colonia war vier jahre lang im internat
des hochalpinen instituts
weiner hat mit ihrer behinderung
natürlich ganz andere voraussetzungen
aber sie wird sind hat gleichwohl eine
hohe meinung von ihr
ein wettkampftyp rossi kann wenn es die
welt geht hat im schwimmen oder den
langlauf dann kann sie sehr viele sehr
viele leistungen aus das ist die ganze
stadt
und da
das ist vielleicht auch ein wenig jede
behinderung also sie sie hat eine starke
kopf so dass das ganze gleich stark
gewählt
marina ist mehrfache schweizer meisterin
im schwimmen im langlauf könnte sie eine
teilnahme bei den paralympics anstreben
aber dafür müsste sie sich in einen
schlitten setzen und das passt ihr nicht
obwohl sie sich fast nur mit den armen
abstoßen kann läuft mit leider mit beim
engadiner frauenlauf mit rund 1000
teilnehmerinnen
ja von keiner
zufrieden
technik ja
müssen wir dafür schauen auf den
edelsten
doppelstock ja was machen wir wenn es
dann wieder schnell gut hat dann gehst
du wie ich einfach war gestern einfach
so schnell ergeben dann ist der
wettkampf kopka oder ich habe gesagt es
betrifft denn das machst du schon naja
das ist minimum sie
[Musik]
oben bei der internatsschule trifft
besuch ein die journalistin vertreter
hofmann welche den artikel mit den
anschuldigungen gegen das hochalpine
institut verfasste ist eingeladen sich
mit der schülerschaft auszutauschen
die veranstaltung in der aula stößt auf
reges interesse
catherine hoffmann war einst selber
schülerin am institut bevor sie
journalistin wurde
[Musik]
rektor steuble zieht es vor nicht in der
aula zu erscheinen prorektor leitl
ergreift das wort
[Musik]
die sich weiterhin unterstützt und wie
sie nun keinen wir hoffen die beste
spiel leitet wie man eigentlich warten
kann bis
zum beispiel nicht mehr
ich persönlich bin voll zu bekommen
gekommen weil zu viel absetzen darf nur
schon diesen artikel das eben auch
setzen ohne von der stelle kommen nicht
was ich die nächsten zwei wochen
an jeder schule gibt es negative sachen
und an dich jeweils so dargestellt dass
wir das ding hier werden
besonders sorgen dass wir hier jeden tag
irgendwie dass das so gemacht
über die aussprache mit den schülern
wird journalistin hoffmann einen
weiteren artikel schreiben und
[Musik]
so reisten auch in der nächsten folge
der internatsschule tann die
schlagzeilen nicht ab rektor gerhard
steuble steht durch die mediale kritik
unter großem druck
batliner gaudenz mit vollgas wenn inga
diener frauenlauf
[Applaus]
und zewa puschkin ist weit im
hintertreffen mit seiner schriftlichen
matura arbeit er versinkt immer tiefer
in schulischen probleme
dann bist du jetzt abschließen und dann
den rest noch fertig machen müssen ich
brauche alles die arbeit muss jetzt ich
musste ja jetzt bewerten
[Musik]